his character history might read like a
Who's Who and likable Goofs but Chevy
Chase has something of a reputation as
one of the meanest men in Showbiz that
rep has followed him all the way from
his rock star Beginnings on Saturday
Night Live in the 70s up to his recent
recurring gig on community highlights
from his worst moments include getting
into a fist fight with Bill Murray and
suggesting that former SNL co-star Terry
Sweeney who was openly gay do a weekly
segment where he would get weighed to
see if he had contracted AIDS yet oh
sorry
Hi fellas it certainly seems like Chevy
Chase has a penchant for rubbing people
the wrong way he even came clean about
it in 2012 when he said nobody prepares
you for what happens when you get famous
and I didn't handle it well that may be
the understatement of the decade